mm-hmm
right good evening and welcome everybody
let's make a start
uh so i'll stop introducing myself my
name is danny kendall i'll be chairing
tonight's meeting of stratfor district
council's planning committee
um and i'll be doing so in accordance
with the rules and procedures are set
out in the front page of your agendas
tonight before we get started a little
bit of housekeeping if that's okay um
mobile phones if you please make sure
those are switched to science or even
off that would be fantastic so we don't
get any um interruptions during the
evening uh the meeting is being live
streamed uh right now on the couch
website and will be available the next
few days on uh youtube as well should
you wish to see it again
what else this is of course uh not a
public meeting it's a meeting held in
public so unless you've registered to
speak you won't be allowed to speak in
this meeting
and finally we're not planning any fire
drills but should there be a fire alarm
well follow me i'll be making a very
quick dash out to the car park there and
you can try and keep up with me i'll be
very fast all right so that's i think
most of that out the way i'm gonna do a
few introductions of officers uh our
representatives committee services
tonight are caroline nash who's at the
back and we've got sophie jarrett here
on my right then on my far right is ross
chambers who's our legal services
representative
on my left is dale barker our planning
manager and then we have our two case
officers joe brook and amy flute uh dale
i believe you've got a statement to make
at this point
i have thank you chair my role tonight
is to provide impartial advice and to
assist members in their decision taking
thank you chair
wonderful thank you dale right i think
that's everything out the way so we
moved to item number one apologies for
absence
thank you chairman we have apologies
from councillors richard and edin
tonight
excellent thank you very much
uh disclosure of interest ah yes
councillor foreman yeah can i declare an
interesting item five i am on the
planning committee of ulster town
council so therefore i will step away
from the table and take no part in that
item thank you very much okay any other
closures of interest no
excellent we have minutes uh of the
meeting held on the 19th of january are
you all content that we signed those
true record
a lot of nodding thank you that's
brilliant in that case
i think we can move to our first
application for the evening
which is item four found on page nine of
your agendas
uh this is application reference twenty
slash zero two five six nine rem and is
long lasting storage depot camden road
lower quentin this is then the
submission of a reserved matters
application for the development of 38
residential dwellings on the eastern
part of the phase b
site
uh presenting officer is joe brook joe
over to you thanks chair i'm just trying
to get it off oh i'm sorry
take a second this was working fine 10
minutes ago
and for some reason it is not coming off
she's got violin manually
yeah that's true but it's still better
than nothing
there you go i'll see if i can make
yours work
you should have bought
just keep swapping around
there we go okay let's do that again so
presenting officer joe brooke over to
you thanks cheers to that
the application site is located at me
unveil as indicated by the black dot
before you
the principle of the residential
development of the application site was
grounded under application reference
one 14011 eight six o u o u t
third to this applicant's further around
applications of 26 prove that in 2016
approve the development of 118 dwellings
on the phase 4b site this is what's
before you on the plan this is phase 4b
in the red line
following from that 2018 application
allowed the alteration of some of the
housing mix constantly consequently the
site subject to this application extend
permission for the development of up to
116 dwellings
the current proposal is for 38 dwellings
which just given this parcel of land is
an increase 11 dwellings from the
previous extant commission
furthermore no additional land is being
proposed to be developed and there is no
loss of meaty land from the extant
permissions this application is for the
redesign of the eastern portion of the
phase 4b development as shown by the
layout plan for you to provide a more
efficient use of the layout and an
alternative mix of dwellings this is
referenced in the officers report
this application would increase the
density of 24.62 dwellings per hectare
from the previous extant permissions
this is still lower than the previous
reserve matter of approvals
on the adjacent phase of the development
at me unveil also the plan before you
gives the indication of the street
scenes and the heights and the proposed
dwelling mix
the dwayne is before you would be
constructed out of red brick and grace
lake with pitch roofs to maintain the
continuity of the rest of the neon veil
development the dweaners would also
utilize modern grey window and door
frames with blue brick detailing on the
principal elevations to help break up
the facade and stand out within the
elevation
this is the application site itself as
you can see so this is the dwellings
that back onto the area so the area is
at the minute of sea
completely blank road has been put in by
after highlight it does have extant
permission on there so they are
permitted to do that
and these are the dwellings that are
done adjacent to the site obviously red
bit detailing gray slate roofs pitch
roofs and also you can see the detailing
has been put in front
overall the application is considered to
be a betterment than the previous
approved extent permission for the
reasons set out in the office report and
is considered to comply with all policy
stipulations and requirements as set out
in the area's development plan
recommendation is therefore for approval
i will also highlight chair that there
is some updates to
the application
we have received a response from the lfa
the local flood authority and they have
now raised no objections so officers
recommendation is for approval
there's also been an amendment to the
national environment section report
ecology did request the condition
however this can be given this is a
reserve matters application we are
obliged to put the conditions on to it
however condition 33 the original
outline does allow that work to be
conditioned so they'd have to
redischarge it furthermore highways have
come back to me and also said they're
satisfied that the construction
management plan that they requested can
be discharged through conditions 31 32
and 46 for the original outline
permission
thank you
thank you joe excellent right so we got
our first speaker uh this is uh peter
haywood please the agent for the
applicant and uh edwards uh from some
modern homes
welcome
so what i didn't cover at the beginning
is we do have covered restrictions still
so we if when you sit down speaking yes
you should go for the hand santa
sometimes at first thank you both and
then of course when you finish if you
wipe down the desk with the um wet wipes
that'd be fantastic as well thank you
both right you have three minutes
between you how are we dividing this up
i think
do the speech myself and then any
questions then excellent okay that's
fantastic right well in that case um mr
hayward you have three minutes uh i'll
give you a warning at the la in the last
10 seconds if that's okay yeah over to
you thank you gentlemen member planning
committee good evening thank you for the
opportunity to speak my name is pete
hayward and i act on behalf of the
applicants from modern homes
i'm joined by sarah edwards planning
management of modern homes should you
have any questions
the application now before you seeks
reserve masters approval for 38
dwellings at phase 4b of me unveil
representing a replant of the eastern
area of this phase
your authority granted outline planning
permission for phase four may unveil in
2015
and most phases are now well advanced
importantly phase 4b already benefits
from reserve matters approval 118
dwellings the majority of this has now
been completed including the affordable
housing
although the eastern area remains
undeveloped
the current proposal seeks to replan the
eastern area in order to deliver a
higher quality design
greater efficiency and a more
appropriate housing mix
the application has been under
consideration since summer 2020
including four rounds of design
amendments and a road safety audit in
response to consulting comments
this has resulted in all technical
considerations being satisfied
the officer has confirmed this
application will deliver several
betterment compared to the approved
scheme
these include enhanced protection of tpo
trees
enhanced landscaping including an
approved landscape buffer
and enhanced housing mix and design
turning to sustainability commitments
the scheme incorporates 15 of the
sustainability credentials set out under
your authority's development
requirements sbd
significantly more than the minimum
requirement of five suitable measures
these commitments include electrical
vehicle charging points for each
proposed home
covered and secure cycle storage at each
proposed home
several cycle and pedestrian links to
the wider area including the greenway to
the west
adaptation to enable each home to
accommodate energy generation
technologies including solar pv panels
sustainable urban drainage systems plus
a 40 allowance for climate change
energy efficiency and carbon reduction
improvements above and beyond those
required by building regs including
higher standards on insulation
water efficiency and carbon reduction
and a 400 meter walking distance to the
local centre and bus stops at my unveil
the proposals are in full accordance
with the outline permission the
development plan and supplementary
guidance
some modern homes are committed to
delivering phase 4be swiftly and to a
high quality to complement the already
established new community at myeonvale
we therefore hope you will support your
office's recommendation and approve this
application which will ensure a
significant betterment compared to the
existing reserve matters approval thank
you
thank you well within your three minutes
right members committee do you have any
questions for the applicants
i think a lot of shaking of heads in
which case thank you both for your time
this evening if you would just give the
desk swipe down many thanks
and we'll get ready for our next speaker
our next speaker is council pertogallo
award member
welcome
you know the routine i think by now
don't you okay yeah thank you right so
you have five minutes if you'd remain
seated for any questions at the end yes
thank you
so um these are additional 30 38 houses
um and as they the applicant just
confirmed they will be part of the new
village of meonvale
and first of all i want to specify that
my objections are with aspects of the
reserve matters they've been proposed by
the developer and these reserve matters
have been submitted after the council
declared the climate emergency and my
point and i hope those of the committees
that we cannot have business as usual
and indeed the applicant's own ambition
according to their website is to be
operationally net zero carbon by 2025
and fully netted zero carbon by 2040 and
stratfor donavan district council own
vision to be one of the first uk carbon
neutral districts supporting zero carbon
construction
so
i'm still waiting for an explanation of
how the development will contribute to
net zero carbon reduction
and while i'm pleased that there is some
engagement with the part 5 climate
mitigation and adaptation sdp
these plans do not go far enough in
terms of environment for the lifespan or
the proposed development
and the last thing we want is to have to
retrofit these houses in 20 years
the proposals while looking at the
efficiency of fabric is based on
statutory planning obligations and
because of the climate emergency which
the council recognized in july 2019
developers building in our district
should be more ambitious
going beyond the current guidelines and
building developments to passive house
standards
in terms of climate habitation and
mitigation
we should build zero carbon or ultra low
energy housing developments with car
free areas
social communal space on car free
streets
and of course the co2 emissions come not
just from ongoing energy using
households but also from construction so
the embodied energy of materials
building fabric and space and water
heating
and travel as well
and so
there is as i understand it there is no
renewable energy provided by the
developers so they are left to be
installed by um
future dwellers um and i don't know what
my understanding is is that not all
dwellings will have ev chargers i'm not
talking about the kind of
the possibility of installing solar
panels but actually i would like uh
solar panels to be installed by the
developers i've asked also for cycle
racks
to you know for visitors coming cycling
um um and so on and
a biodiversity net gain
should be sufficiently demonstrated in
the development
also the houses and garages to the
southwest corner are right up to the
boundary i understand with an open space
so it's important to provide good
boundary treatment here to maintain
privacy but also to improve the
appearance of the rear of the housing
from the open space
there have been instances of surface
water flooding as well as sewage
flooding in neon vale in private gardens
and i'm dealing right now with
complaints from residents in fact
later on i should be writing to say
modern about that and i see that the
local flood authority had objected i see
that there is an update they have
withdrawn their objection at the moment
but um
i i am quite worried about these
repeated incidents in the in very new
houses in in the new part of my unveil
and
um so that link to my understanding that
there are um
the permeable paving is only for four
plots
and i think that all our surfaces
including footways should be permeable
unless there is a good reason otherwise
i also ask that an accessibility audit
is undertaken i see drop curbs where
drives are
but we need drop kerbs for pedestrians
and those using mobility scooters
wheelchairs and buggies to ensure there
are drop curbs in all junctions to
enable people to move around safely and
to reach the community facilities from
this new development we're having quite
a lot of problems in the um
already inhabited part of neonvale where
there's a lack of drop curbs and we're
having problems with of connectivity
and we are complaining about that but
because roads are unadopted
the councils can do very much so it's
very important that a planning stage
we get this right also in view of the
equality act 2010
so for this reason 10 seconds yeah i
urge the planning committee to reject
the application until a better
environmentally friendly scheme is
presented thank you
any questions for our member from the
committee
no
seeing shaking heads that case thank you
very much for your time as well if you
could just wipe things down that'd be
fantastic thank you
okay those are our speakers on the first
application um let's move to points for
clarification do we have any questions
at this point councillor jennings and
counsel thank you chairman uh the
council has just mentioned about drop
curves
get some clarification on that
the only thing that i could really
clarify on that point is this
application has gone through heavy
consultation with warwickshire current
highways and they've now comfortable
with road safety audits and all sorts
that's been required from it and they've
come back with no objections to the
layouts drop curves may be a problem
there but our statutory council tease
hasn't raised that as a major issue so
they're happy with it
okay thank you
council adam
thanks a slight list i'll try and rattle
through them um
i noticed that the on the the site
layout as it is in the report includes
the whole sort of area and that it's
segmented somewhat onto the on the plan
that we've got am i is that the east
west that's referenced
so what it is so let me go to that one
this is phase 4b in its entirety
so that was granted outline permission
so what this is a section of that phase
will be which you're allowed to do under
a separate reserve matters application
so this before you is only for this
redline boundary in front of you but
that but it's part of the same outline
that was granted as the phase 4b area so
me unveiling 2014 let me try and see if
we get my point and point working
all this was permitted in 2014 the red
line here
is the phase 4b area
this reserve matters application is for
that it passes within the phase 4b area
so that's why it's like that in the
report because it is
segmented but that's how it is our own
planning yeah sure and
in terms of the whole 4b i'm
not sort of trying to go outside the
boundaries of this particular um
application but the the question on
affordable housing mix was in in the
report from the ward member and i take
it that's
something this is fairly standard for
this type of application or is it
something we did yeah it is the reason
being is the full housing stuff also is
covered under the outline and it's part
of section 106 so the affordable housing
area isn't part of this area and you can
see there's been no ejection from the
full housing team and sdc policy for
that very reason it doesn't affect the
affordable housing if it was in the area
where the full marriage has already been
agreed via the 106 or something that
would be something we would have to
consider but that's why we've got no
objection that's great um so for clarity
just just just to clarify that i'm
looking at joe to make sure i've got
this right
the total amount of affordable housing
on 4b
is
correct for the total number of houses
on 4b even with these extra 11 houses
that's correct because what it is is
fundamentally in this area yeah no i
thought so from the reading of the
report but i just wanted some clarity
for the countries the only other ones
then i've got um
i think the board member did ask about
the
number of ev charging points for all
dwellings
the honest truth being with that is the
ev charging points you have to go to the
original outlying permission and it
wasn't requirement the outline
permission ev charging points
unfortunately for the roma application
isn't a consideration so they are
proposing it as part of their climate
change checklist but i can't condition
that to be put in
to the development so it's part of the
climate change checklist so it could
well be the case it's not for all
dwellings but you have to consider that
there was no
the 116 drains there doesn't require it
at all
okay so again council what we're saying
here is that's one of the betterments
yeah we have achieved some ev charging
whereas previously we had none
and
we are not in a position to say to the
developer you must provide 100 tv
charging on this application future ones
we will be not on this one because of
its history okay yeah thank you for
clarification on that and the last one
was you know the um
that they've gone well beyond the
minimum requirements for the the
measures for climate change considering
that was such a concern of the ward
member are you able to just elaborate
i mean i know they've they they have
they've got this is that this is the
issue
the ward members very wrong what's
saying it's very admirable but we have
to consider the policy requirements and
the spd requirements it's just the way
it is if it goes to appeal for them
reasons it's
going to be very very hard to defend
against they have met them requirements
and gone above them
we can't ask more than what they've
submitted yeah no that's fine let's say
it's just for clarification from my
point of view reading it so thank you
for that okay we've got council dixon
next then curtis then i'll catch you
guys
thanks chairman um the outline planning
permission uh was that also in favor of
the same developer or was it in respect
of a previous developer because we've
got an application here which is
obviously
increasing the density of 4b
um i appreciate that we've just heard
that the number of affordable houses etc
meets the higher volume now being
proposed and it's also indicated in the
report
that the proposed housing mix is more in
line with our own policy though it's
definitely a
definite change on what was previously
there in the outline um but is it
is the outline and this applicant the
same or
are we dealing with a
subsequent developer you're dealing with
a number of developments developers on
me unveiled so when it was permitted in
2018 sorry 24 to our 2015 but the
applications 2014 reference
it was for the whole site they the areas
have been subdivided by various
developers as you often get with them
um so it
is what i had anticipated thank you
gentlemen
yeah i do apologize to the dale's rose a
very good point there the previous
reserve matters for phase 4b is saying
modeling is the same applicant that has
got the extent permission for the
reserve matters application the outline
you've got red row here you've got sent
mod wins there and various at different
areas so 116 is the same developer
i believe so yeah it certainly is in
this area yeah whether it is so i'm
completely honest this area here might
not be saint marwins but i'll tell you
what i'll see even better
these dwellings here are saint modern
dwellings which is adjacent to the site
okay i've got my alice councillor curtis
next report of clarification
yes um
thank you
um
so i'm just going back to the affordable
housing joe
um
do we know or can you tell committee
what you say in there in the report on
page 16 the proportion of and provision
of affordable housing within phase b
phase 4b
won't be affected but presumably if
there are
more houses being built
the proportion of affordable housing
will be affected can you tell us what
the
proportion of affordable housing in
for phase 4b
will now be
it will stay the same phase will be the
portion of the four
is this in this area here so that's 10
units in that area there and that stays
the same that's why you've got no
ejection from the affordable housing
team but what is the pr the percentage
of affordable housing within 4b
that will be itself it would be
it's around about 30 percent
previously but the issue i have to
highlight with that is that you are now
referencing an application outside of
this so at the minute the affordable
housing doesn't affect the overall
development we are only considering this
reserve matters application in front of
us
and we've got a no objection from the
full housing team saying that it still
meets the requirements of all the
housing
thank you chair i must have i'm still
slightly struggling that if there are 11
more houses being built
it must it must affect the proportion
of affordable housing within
this i mean just my map you're going to
should be one the reason being you're
going back to the section one of six
requirements under the original outline
application so it does get quite
complicated under the section one he
said i agree it's an intensification the
the density there but they're still
under affordable housing requirements
and the full housing team raised no
objection for this reason the opinion
that it still meets the policy
requirements under the section 106. so
for that on their purposes they've
raised no objection to this reserve
matters application they consider it's a
better housing mix and a better a
betterment to what it is overall because
it's a higher density
if i make counsellor i
i i think you're right
the proportion must have changed if
there are more houses the proportion
must have changed but the answer that
we're getting from your policy team is
that the number is acceptable
right
the proportion will have changed
marginally yes because of that
yeah i think we've got the answer to
that i think we'll move on council
fleming
you chairman
my question is um
being part of the same climate change
group as the ward member um why there's
only four houses
with uh permeable driveways um i mean
seem to mention that there's a lot of
slabs and
and pavia bricks and whatever else but
only four houses with permeable
driveways which i thought was going to
be a a fairly high thing because to
eliminate and reduce water run up
that comes down to three points to be
honest uh firstly
if you have a look in the landscaping
bit these they have to re-discharge the
hard and soft landscaping so we can
cover that bit when that comes to that
point of part of the outline secondly
the third authority have assessed it and
raised no objections so their opinion is
what is being proposed through the
modeling and the materials and a lot is
sufficient and thirdly they still have
to meet building regulations and the
land drainage act if this was ever
permitted
okay any more points for clarification
if not let's go to the debate you want
to start council jennings
thank you chairman uh
first of all i say i mean i applaud the
great aspirations of the ward member
here
but
um
they're meeting the current legislation
or
or policy requirements
in fact what they're doing is they're
going above and beyond that
um
and if it complies with all the policy
requirements
there are no statutory objections at all
and to go against the officers
um
decisional recommendations we have to
come up with very good valid planning
reasons and i see no good planning
reasons to go against the officer's
recommendation so i'm
i'm happy to actually recommend this
that we go with the officer's
recommendation just still check that's
proposal for the week thank you council
dixon
my concern is over the housing mix um
and looking at the foot of page 15 so
members
um where cs 19 preferred housing mix is
a loud four
bedroom or larger than four bedroom
fifteen to twenty percent
so if we take 20 percent
of the 38
that gives me a maximum of seven point
something or other but makes a maximum
of eight
however there's 13 of such properties in
this phase
and yet the officers indicate that the
proportion of four plus bedrooms is
marginally over
i'd say it's about 50 over
um and therefore uh there is a move
within this application against
the
prior outline permission
for a reduction
in the number of
two-bedroomed houses they're going down
from 34 of the approval to 21 of the
approval
three-bedroomed houses are going down
from 40 percent of the approval to 34 of
the approval
but the 4-bedroomed and 5-bedrooms are
going up from 21
to 34
so there is a move within this
application for taking small removing
smaller houses two-bedroom properties
and increasing the number of four and
five-bedroom properties
now we might be within the
parameters of appropriate density
but i find this as a situation whereby a
developer is basically saying i can get
more bang for my bucks if i build larger
houses
so i must admit i would wonder what
necessarily the parish might have been
thinking regarding an ndp and whether or
not there's a need for four and
five-bedroomed houses and local locality
or whether the housing mix is being
skewed to more expensive properties
thank you uh anybody else in to speak in
the debate on this
i'll add my thoughts uh at this point
then i
understand what you're saying uh
councillor dixon but i i feel that
i i feel we've got adequate answers from
the officers and the team are happy with
the with the housing mix
like house of jennings i look i i mean i
think council had
excellent
very admirable and in a perfect world
i'd be saying here absolutely let's go
with higher standards that'd be great we
don't live in a perfect world we would
it would be unreasonable for us to
expect
this developed to go any any further
than they've gone and if it did go to
appeal we wouldn't win that appeal i
think it's a good development as it set
out and i'm happy to second the
recommendation that we approve uh the
application
does anybody else want to speak before
we go to a vote
councillor curtis
i'm just agreeing with councillor dixon
on the housing mix if we're looking for
you know it doesn't conform with policy
cs19 but i believe um given the
percentages that you've
uh
outlined for us and i will be voting
against on that basis
well fine okay anyone else want to speak
in that case i think we go to the vote
um i don't think we have to update
anything the conditions are still the
same aren't they so in that case the
proposal is that we approve subject to
the llfa approval all those in favor of
granting please show
six
okay those against
three okay
therefore the committee resolves to
grant application reference twenty slash
zero two five six nine slash rem we can
move to our next application we'll just
do a
bit of musical chairs for a moment
we'll just pause
okay then our second application for the
evening
i'll go too quickly don't worry is um
item five found on page 23 of the agenda
pack uh the application application
reference then is 21
0 3 4 8 2
ful this is milhouse birmingham road
kings i always it is king's curtain
isn't it i think i'm looking for a local
person i'm pronouncing that correct yeah
thank you thought so king's curtain um
and presenting officer is amy flute uh
i've still not said what it is it's the
removal storage buildings palisade fence
breaking up a removal concrete slab to
facilitate construction got detached
dorma bungalow and carriage along with
associated works amy over to you thank
you chairman
the site donated by the black dot is an
open countryside location washed over by
the greenbelt and is designated as arden
special landscape area
the application site is edged red
the blue line indicates other land
within the applicant's ownership this
includes mill house to the east and
streamways to the west in addition there
are other dwellings within the
applicant's ownership not indicated on
this plan
the site edge red has a public footpath
al 58 running through it the nearest
listed building coloured red on the plan
is to the east
planning permission is sought for the
construction of a detached dormer
bungalow with garage along with all
other associated works including the
change of use of the land from land use
currently for storage of caravans to
residential use
a wild flower meadow and orchard are
proposed to the south of the site um
the palisade fence along the east and
southern boundary will be removed
and public footpath um al 58 will
require a diversion order in order to
facilitate the development
elevations of the dwellings and garage
can now be seen it is proposed to use
red brick and tile
dwellings will have two bedrooms sorry
the dwelling will have two bedrooms and
a large living space with office at
ground floor
these images are taken from the site's
frontage looking in a south and south
easterly direction public footpath ar-58
intersects the site
at this point caravan storage operates
along both the eastern and western sides
of the site
the site southern boundary can now be
seen looking in a northerly direction
from public footpath al-58 the existing
storage building and palisade fencing
will be removed
looking towards the site now in a
southwesterly direction as i said the
palestine fence will be removed and the
diverted public footpath if an order is
approved would run along the boundary
that can be seen all of the conifer
trees which you can see are to be
removed
the top image shows neighboring property
streamways to the west of the site and
the bottom image looking in an easily
direction shows stream ways garage and
greatly listed milhouse in the distance
chairman there are an in-principal
objection to a dwelling in this location
and the loss of employment land has not
been justified in addition harm to the
green belt has been identified it is not
considered that there are very special
circumstances to outweigh the harm to
the green bout and the other identified
harm chairman the recommendation is to
refuse the application for the reasons
as detailed within the committee reports
please note that there are some updates
on the update sheet too thank you
thank you amy right we'll go to our
first speaker on this application that's
the um ulster town council councilor
mike beau chairman
welcome counselor
thank you so you have three minutes if
you'd remain seated for any questions at
the end
and of course you're already sanitizing
which is brilliant thank you for that
not yet there's a little button in the
middle if you press that perfect can
hear you now okay three minutes over to
you
uh last year mr turner with others uh
presented the company's enhanced
business strategy to further exploit
european markets that account for 75 of
the company's sales to date to acc atc
planning committee for the strategy to
be successful some senior management
functions need to be changed into two
defined roles
one improving and promoting existing
models and development of new products
and two day-to-day logistical and
management needs of the estate which
also houses other businesses including
an expanding leading precision
manufacturer
previously successful business
development strategies have resulted in
job creation which can be seen in the 28
increase in the number of permanent
employees since july 2020
the additional dwelling was born out of
the need to attract a person of suitable
caliper for the logistical and overall
management of the estate
turning to the planning office's reasons
for refusal firstly the dwellings
remoteness this is the plan the officer
stating the dwellings remoteness from
shops facilities and services identified
need and functional need not met
therefore not sustainable development
we find this surprising given that
existing housing and immediate vicinity
is adequately served
further that the company's business
strategy does indeed demonstrate an
identifiable need together with a
functional need
secondly the proposal would result in a
loss of employment use
mr turner is the employee in this
instance and he's difficult to conclude
as he owns the business that his
employment is at risk
the question of compromise of what
comprises an existing employment site is
a matter of planning judgment
the oxford definition of judgment is the
ability to make considered decisions to
come to sensible conclusions
atc consent contend that the sensible
conclusion
is that classify in this areas of loss
of employment use stretches this
definition
and lastly that the proposal is
inappropriate development within the
green palette and harmful to the green
belt by definition stating that very
special circumstances do not exist in
this case
the case officer is however mindful that
if permission is forthcoming the
applicant will accept the condition to
tie the dwelling to the business to
restrict its sale on the open market the
officer concludes that this does not
amount to a bsc given that it's not
being found that there is a need for
additional dwelling to be linked to the
business
again atc believes this asserts that if
the need was found this would constitute
the vsc
and we contend that the companies plan
the match to a very special circumstance
and satisfies the essential need
elements
to conclude the company's business
strategy designed to enhance the
company's sales has the potential for
further job creation and is the driving
force behind this application
the need for an additional dwelling is
brought out to the evaluation by the
company regarding the day-to-day
testicles
and management needs of the estate
we feel that refusal will stifle future
job creation and therefore auster town
council supports this application on the
grounds that the business is likely to
provide local opportunities for growth
in job creation and economic benefits to
the wider local community perfect thank
you very much any questions from the
committee please
no looks like you're getting off lightly
i'll let you wipe down the button on the
desk thank you thank you and we can move
to our next uh speaker
which is uh tony turner the applicant
and liz uh
nicholson
if you'd like to come up
okay and to double check this you've got
three minutes between you um
so you'll answer questions who's going
to be speaking here mr turner's going to
speak and i'm just here for a question
thank you
right well welcome both you have three
minutes between you um
mr turner if you and and from nicholson
if you'd like to remain seated at the
end for any questions over to you thank
you thank you mr chairman members
in 1963 i started turner engineering to
produce the world's first flail merge
cutting roadside verges and hedges
green match
agreement limiters was established in
1993 to design and manufacture a range
of british wood chippers and green waste
shredders it has become a leading
manufacturer in europe and since your
meeting on the 29th of september when we
were employing 110 at that point this
has now increased to 123
we have a massive order book your recent
approval to expand our production
facilities is much appreciated
to achieve our production target we have
invested another million pounds in the
state of the art machines
to maximize output we are now operating
two shift systems and within six months
our labor force will exceed 140.
we have our own green mech sales and
support companies in germany and france
my grandson is ceo of france overseas by
my daughter both companies still sell
more than the uk 80 percent of our
production is exported helped
considerably by two queens awards for
export and innovation
turner r d owns the industrial estate
and 26 acres alongside one kilometer of
the river arrow immediately upstream of
ulster since announcing my intention to
rewild the gland i've agreed a request
from the environment agency and wildlife
trust to consider forming a wetlands
area to create a natural flood
prevention scheme to further mitigate
flooding in ulster and provide a haven
for aquatic wildlife 100 plus trees to
form an avenue creating a park-like
setting the flock of sheep and other
farm animals areas are being adopted by
local schools to educate children in
countryside matters my own background is
in farming and agricultural engineering
the four cottages at the mill and two
lodges provide affordable accommodation
for employees on the estate
my three children each own one-third of
both companies cheryl in france is
company secretary to both jonathan's
managing director of green make my third
daughter rebecca and family need a new
modest house tied to the estate to
manage the security of the industrial
estate the 26 acre parkland the animals
and increased schools activity perhaps
we should call it jubilee park leaving
me to continue my passion developing
innovative products seeking new export
markets and ensuring ongoing employment
and the business continues to prosper
and that it remains in control of my
family for future generations continuing
living up to the turner r d statement
which is engineering for a greener
environment thank you perfect i was just
going to give you the one for 10 seconds
excellent timing okay any questions
please from the cookie council jennings
just a quick one um
why does your business need someone
extra on the site rather than within a
five mile radius i'm sorry
sorry i i speak this
why does the business need someone on
site rather than living within i say a
five mile radius
well because in fact you know there is a
a lot of um
[Music]
movements traffic movements for example
also from the security point of view but
also too
you know with what we're being asked to
do by from the environment point of view
um we're forming um you know
a small
farming enterprise if you like but
with with animals etc and we need
somebody you know living on site you
know to to to attend to these of course
as well as organizing the movements that
we're
getting from the schools and and if we
open it up more to the public
any other questions please
no
in that case thank you both for your
time this evening thank you
oh hold on a sec one more question one
more question go on council jennings
just in time
and this is more of a technical side um
there was no marketing evidence produced
why was that
it's simply because
a letter has been provided by trust
loves
state agency surveyors
that
there is no other use for this site than
caravan storage um
which is apparent as well because it's
in the green belt i mean
you're not going to be able to use this
site and put new buildings up of
that of the size and scale
that people want for modern employment
purposes to get a
valuable return the caravans are run by
mr turner along with all the other
business things he has it doesn't employ
anybody it's not an employment site at
the moment
and trustloves have confirmed there
really is no other use for the site
because in the greenbelt
planning would would not really support
that
well in that case second time around
thank you very much for your time
tonight thank you
go to our final speaker on this
application which is the ward member
welcome council cargill thank you
members
right this application is to build a
modest home tied to the business for the
director rebecca and family
also town council have stated this
application does not in their view harm
their vision of the ndp particularly
policy hbe1 and the 8s10 and cs10 are
not applicable in this case the
reference to the officer's comments on
ec4 and change of use
the explanatory note in the dndp 62.2.14
goes on to describe that this policy
seeks to protect existing employment
sites within the town by resisting their
change of use to residential not in the
countryside i do not therefore believe
that this application is against the
ulster ndp
regarding the caravan storage site which
you've been discussing the report states
that this is run by one person the
applicant it was until last year the
applicant's wife who ran it until her
passing
caravan's count as the us just describes
come and go making them temporary
buildings however up to 30 caravans have
consistently been stored there for over
20 years
therefore it can actually be described
as permanent storage
the lawful development certificate only
allows for caravan storage limiting
further economic use
the quoted chartered surveyor's report
states that the site has no beneficial
commercial use apart from caravan
storage
the office's report goes on to say that
what compromises some comprises an
existing employment site as a matter of
planning judgment
i agree
caravan storage has never been a
full-time job and no one can make a
full-time living from it there is a
state in the report very little
opportunity to increase employment here
whereas in the last year greenmack have
employed as we've just heard over 13
additional stuff
this also demonstrates that the current
accommodation described by the applicant
is needed for the workers of the factory
the owner and applicant is a local
businessman has provided employment in
the air for many years the business is
expanding and security of the site comes
with that we're all seeing an increase
in rural crime
and rebecca will not only be responsible
security of the site but also the wider
management which we've just heard about
the applicant mentioned they have grown
plans to grow the company which is
something i support and i do not wish to
see that jeopardized
the applicant has mentioned a grand
vision for the area
surrounding this the site and will need
that will need management the
opportunities for natural landscape
flood meadows rewiring and educational
opportunity supplements are i believe
significant
moving to the green park concerns i am a
supporter and defender of the principal
agreeing about however in my opinion in
this case the harm identified is
significantly less than substantial
the officer's report notes that cs 10
supports the partial or complete
redevelopment of a previously developed
brownfield site with a redundant or
continuing use subject to it not having
a material greater impact on the
openness of the greenbelt
by removing up to 30 caravans an
incongruous palisade fence a large
concrete slab tin shed and other debris
well i think those who are able to visit
site will agree with me that this will
be a significant betterment to the area
the proposed development is effectively
concealed from view it's not on the main
road or in full visibility considering
the removal of the caravans with the
building of a modest drilling i feel
that this will not harm the openness of
the countryside
the grand vision and the special circus
under special circumstances as far as
i'm concerned for the site includes the
proposed relocation investment of the
public footpath improved access into the
countryside
access to schools for educational
purposes and for people to come and
enjoy nature
appropriate screening of the dwelling
from the footpath is proposed
members in summary you have the support
of the town council my support no
objections to the dwelling no readily
visible harm to the openness of the
countryside no loss of employment in
fact an increase
sustained improved sustainability reuse
of browfield site betterment to the site
significant landscape improvements
rewilding educational
opportunities potential flood mitigation
and importantly the potential to help
and secure a rural businesses prosperity
into what can be an exciting future
members i hope you will agree with me
that this is all about planning balance
and i believe that the proposed
improvements outweigh any harm that has
been identified thank you
thank you any questions for the world
member
no just one from
council fleming
the um
the fact that
somebody wants to live on site is this
part and parcel of
i know i can't remember whether it was
talked about but if you're gonna have
livestock on there
you got this extra person on site
because you've got live stuff close by
is that one of the reasons and why it
can then be tied to the business as a
dwelling rather than open market housing
that's one of the reasons council i
think the important thing is the as as
mentioned by the uh the applicant there
are a significant number of vehicle
movements um through that site day well
not all night because they got a double
shift now because of the increased
capacity of the works so that's one part
of it that element but also yes there
will be the the actual management of the
actual site when you complete
my one question for the what member is
what a lot has been made of the
educational asset where's the nearest
school and how far away is it
well the actual fact it's um what is it
it's ulster grammar school and as it so
happens some of the um yeah i'm aware i
don't know yes things i teach
how far away is it by walking in how
long would it take to walk to the site
from say ulster grammar school
now for me it'd be about 15 minutes for
a youngster probably 10.
you know it's um it is we the the
applicant is engaged for the the school
and they've been doing a uh wildlife
project on his land already and that
they are discussing some of the other
elements of that
for future educational use
okay thank you very much any other
questions council jennings
so do you know how many members of the
family actually live on site at the
moment
i believe
um
mr turner i don't know i i i don't know
if there are no further questions
but we'll move on thank you very much
for your time
i think uh ross i'm just going to say
for clarity i'm sure you'll be happy
with this i had no idea that ulster
grammar school
points of clarification what have we got
council mills
thank you very much amy um
it's been
quite a bit made by about loss of um
employment and you've got that on the
page 37 and uh
elsewhere on page 28.
do we know how do we know how much it
loss of employment
or
gauge and approximate
um so
for this application obviously the the
loss of employment which we are looking
at is obviously the loss of the land for
the storage of caravans so as um mr
turner said i think it's just mr turner
that is involved with the storage um
caravan business at the moment it used
to be his wife before her passing um
but um as set out in the officers report
the
area of land is currently
being used for the storage of caravans
and it is considered um officers
consider um that for the purpose of
policy um
cs22 and the ndp policy is engaged um
and obviously there needs to be it needs
to be demonstrated um
that effectively it's no longer viable
um
for the for the business so um for
example the development management
considerations um
state that
this is for policy as-10 um
will require sufficient evidence to
demonstrate that there is an essential
need for a personal person to be present
on the site at all times
um
sufficient to justify the provision of a
residential accommodation a case based
solely on grounds of security will not
necessarily be sufficient sorry i've
just read you the wrong paragraph with
my report
let me just find find the right point
sorry i highlighted the wrong area
i found it now
so policy cs22 stipulates that an
existing employment site should not be
redeveloped or converted to
non-employment uses unless it is no
longer viable or appropriate for
business purpose a rigorous assessment
of each proposal of that nature will be
undertaken
jim if i can add to that
members will be familiar with the mppf
they'll be familiar that the mppf says
that it has to be read
as a whole
can't just focus on the odd word here
and there but that's generally the case
when deciding planning applications
can i just
encourage members
not to focus on this one element
and see it as as pivotal or
determinative it's a very small element
of officers concern
obviously officers
when they're writing the reports we have
to look at all of your policies we have
to give you advice on all of your
policies and this is a conflict with one
of your policies but it's a very small
element of the total reasons for for
refusal in in the officer report so yes
by all means explore it but don't see
this as purely determinative of the
application all right never every right
to ask though on it absolutely
absolutely um any other points of
clarification at this point
no
yeah carry on just actually following on
um matt's uh uh how far from shops are
we there
there's i know there's a pub um i'm not
aware that there are any shops in king's
coating um so i would assume that you'd
have to drive to the shops the nearest
um location and as i say i'm i'm
personally i'm not aware of any shops um
in the village but
but i could be wrong
counselor adam
thanks i'm just on the use of the site
for the caravans as a business as it is
is there a potential fallback situation
in terms of what the site could be used
for in terms of business i mean
obviously there's been some
change from from the the passing of the
person who originally managed it which
indicates there could be a change in the
use of the site
business-wise i saw just exploring how
that how that's viewed from a planning
point of view
obviously the lawful development
certificate allows the land to be used
for the storage of the caravans um so
my understanding would be if there was
any deviation from that potentially a
fresh planning application would be
required for that to be considered
again cherry if i can if i can add to
that um i think on the site inspection
members saw
that this company make a number of
wheeled vehicles that can be towed
behind cars or vans
presumably with their expanding
production they occasionally need
storage space and the ideal place to
store small wheeled vehicles that can be
towed behind cars is a place where
caravans are lawfully stored and that
would be totally lawful
so there is a potential use there for
the current business
all right uh any other questions
yes i'll try councilman's policies um i
i don't i missed the point uh
there's no conf is there a conflict the
ndp i'm just looking
yeah
i just can you um
again so within the reasons for the the
reason for refusal
the reasons for refusal which are set
out within the officer report
um
that if there has been identified that
there is conflict with the ndp um so
policy h if i go if you go to the
principal section of the report um
in relation to the erection of a
dwelling
um
[Music]
turning to the ndp policy hbe1
identified identifies the site as a
countryside location and stipulates that
new housing in the countryside will only
be supported in accordance with
paragraph 79 of the mppf that's now
paragraph 70 um paragraph 80 and
policies as10 and cs10 of the core
strategy um so we've identified conflict
with the ndp policy in that instance and
obviously the core strategy um
also conflict with the ndp in relation
to policy ec4 as well
councillor fleming
having listened to that and having
listened to the town councillor um he
said he was quite happy with the the uh
the the this building being built and it
didn't defend them in terms of their ndp
i just wonder where we're at a
difference with the town council and and
the the planning officer
i'm not sure if that's something you can
answer really is it maybe i think maybe
we'll come back to that as part of the
debate really okay
okay um
any other questions no
let's go to the debate then
council dixon
thank you chairman
i agree with the uh with the board
member um but uh amy could we possibly
put up the photographs please of the
site as it is now
um the ones there we are that'll do i
think probably situation whereby and i'm
now looking at page 31 final paragraph
where it opens up overall it is
considered that the proposal would have
a significantly greater impact on the
green belt in terms of openness as a
matter of fact
i would
disagree um those caravans i agree
understanding planning terms they're
temporary buildings and could be moved
etc uh and obviously another uh reason
which we could use that same piece of
land or the owners could use that same
piece of land would be for storing his
wood chippers
and but even if each of those caravans
was replaced by a wood chipper i would
think probably i would still have the
same opinion
that a single a two-bedroom bungalow in
replacement of those i would not see as
significantly impacting and harming the
greenbelt i would actually regard and
agree with the councillor the ward
member that it would be an improvement
and therefore in truth i will not be
supporting the officer's recommendation
on this one
thank you
anybody else wish to comment counselor
adam
yeah i don't
i think i do agree with councillor dixon
i'm finding it hard to
accumulates or the the hard um
planning reasons against it which i was
asking about potential fallbacks and
things but i think
the balance of this which is what the
world member talked about was that the
harm wasn't going to be substantial in
the way that
is being sort of suggested and i
apologize i couldn't make the site visit
but you can see from the photos that
that it's not sort of the most
attractive view in the countryside as it
is and obviously it is visible from
from
a footpath i'm not going to make a
proposal just yet because i've like said
i haven't got something hard to sit on
uh
for that kind of reasoning but
i am that's the way i'm going at the
moment based on the planning balance i
say
thank you cats mills
thanks mr chairman yes i
i have to say i think would be an
improvement having um
dwayne there and uh
unfortunately amy i will go against the
officer's recommendation on that thank
you
council jennings
yeah i think we've got to be a bit
careful about it though because what
you're saying is that any field you've
got with caravans you just pile it full
of junk and it's going to look better if
we get rid of it and put a house in its
place
it's in the middle of the green belt
you know it is it is what it is and just
because
it's got something there which you don't
particularly like at the moment
doesn't give you
a reason
just say
yeah we
because that just
it means everyone say who's got a field
they can pile old cars in there parlor
caravans and say it will look better if
there's a nice five-bedroom house there
which of course it will but
that's not the way it works
councilman mills and then capsule yeah
as i understand all it could be
landscaped you're gonna take the the
college has got to go i mean it
it just got to be an improvement mr
chairman
council fleming
i still see this as related to
potential employment
of somebody else on the land because of
the i'm not saying it should be an
agricultural tie or an agricultural
restriction but certainly limited to the
to the businesses within the site um
and
i i don't see the harm the problem i
have is um
coming up with the special circumstances
to defeat the greenbelt object so
so in general
i wouldn't support the officer's
recommendation but
i'm not sure i can come up with all
the reasons myself as to why
right councillor curtis the council
crumb um
i think we should also
take into account the
support from from the town council and
their neighborhood development plan
which i think i do feel sometimes we
don't always give due weight to
local neighborhood development plans
thank you okay
councillor trump
apologies mr chairman our slight point
of clarification i was a bit dense and
bit slow less of many apologies
has the application
um got a tie
to the uh
to the business in this was it actually
proposed i can't sit anywhere but is
there a tie proposed
of that it's a fair question so i do
apologize if i have missed that so
within the supporting documentation um
the applicant has said that they would
be willing to accept a condition to
effectively tie
the dwelling to the business but they
didn't originally propose a tie
the it's with it's within the planning
statement that they would um
they would obviously be willing to have
a condition to that effect
yeah
if i may
the fact that it's offered doesn't make
a condition lawful or acceptable
and my advice to you would be
that
personal conditions of this nature are
not acceptable for agricultural workers
dwellings
for agricultural workers dwellings they
have to be available to the agricultural
community
not to one specific farm
and i think this that condition is very
unlikely
to so to pass the tests
for a planning condition and i'm sure
your your legal advisor can can give you
some more advice on that
and for clarity this is not being
proposed as an agricultural worker's
dwelling is it not not from agricultural
workers but equally it's not being
proposed to tie it to the business okay
that's the report you've got in front of
you is for a standalone dwelling
absolutely i think that's important we
keep uh keep in mind
ross did you want to comment further are
you happy with that
yeah just to just to say that it's not
being proposed as an agricultural type
it's being as i understand it proposed
that
the occupier of the dwelling will work
at the adjacent business
you know it would need to pass the tests
for any planning condition
and we can maybe explore that
potentially it could be the subject of a
legal agreement as well
but it would that would need to be
necessary to make the development
acceptable
so we need to demonstrate very clearly
that it's
linked tied as part of the business
and it has very special circumstances as
well
all right um we've gone through
everybody listed so far i'm going to add
my thoughts
i i'm not seeing the the grounds for
this and i'm uncomfortable with what
people are suggesting in that
like counselor jennings said i think you
know it's a field because it looked
better to put a house on it well we
could all agree with that but we have
got our set of rules and regulations
that state very clearly we've got to
find very special circumstances well i'm
not seeing them here i'm not seeing very
special circumstances being presented
i'm seeing
a a site where where it would be nice to
put a house
but there's no tie to the business no
formal tie
being proposed it's not agricultural
workers dwelling as we would understand
it i'm just not seeing
the reasons to go for this i'm sorry but
i'm just not and what's my i asked him
uh beforehand in briefing to clarify how
this is different to the previous
application
that this committee refused
before
and i'm not seeing any noticeable
difference not any major difference i'm
seeing certain cosmetic things around
the side but i'm not seeing any major
difference so for them for me i'm going
to be supporting the officer's
recommendation on this and it's not been
proposed yet but i'm going to put it out
there and propose that we refuse this
application in in line with the
officer's recommendation now um
councillor dixon you've been waving at
me go ahead
thank you jeremy just thought i wanted
to comment on the uh what council
jennings has said about the fact that
you know just put a load of cars and
dumps and normalized it into a field and
that basically let's change all that for
a nice house
well the answer is this one's got a
lawful development certificate for
actually having caravans and if somebody
with a field decided they fill it with
fuller junk that junk would have to be
removed enforcement etc because they
wouldn't have permission to create
storage
on a basically green field in the green
belt so that is a
is not a reason for saying that
it could easily be replicated elsewhere
that's for one the other us to special
circumstances um
the planners can correct me if i'm wrong
but special circumstances required when
harm is identified if we actually come
to the conclusion that a bungalow is
less harmful than that do we need very
special circumstances to approve it
is the question and finally
when it comes to tying properties i
wondered where we are regarding
application
1702031 which was for two lodge type
homes to provide affordable
accommodation etc now i think they were
tied to the business
and therefore if those were tied to the
business presumably
a bungalow could be tied to the business
as well
i'll let dale have a think about that
we'll go to council jennings
let's come back on on that but
what you're saying that way is that
every caravan site is a potential
building plot
i would agree with what you just said
there i mean that is effectively what
you're saying but my understanding of
caravan by definition it's not permanent
it moves around councillor crump
thank you mr tim um
i think there's definitely merit in this
application but i still think
judging from the debate we've had so far
there's still some uncertainties about
things about this application
um
and about whether there's a functional
or essential need for the person to be
on site
um
and i know security was mentioned and
then i've heard that this potential
night shift or there's as there's
more people using the site throughout
the day and potentially the evening at
night and i might be paraphrasing there
wrongly but i think i'm getting some
nonsense so
there may be security concerns that have
been addressed by
more people on the site
but notice that i'm using the word may
because i'm not
i haven't got information in front of me
or i may have missed it but
it's just this element of uncertainty
and i know a next counselor
i'd like to party counselor used to be
on this planning committee if it's not
quite right it's wrong and i would just
like to see a bit more evidence on this
that there is this essential need
and
it can be demonstrated and independently
very hard to say we need it because of x
y and z
and we'll be able to expand the business
safeguard the business and we'll be able
to offer all these different things to
do with the environment to do with
education to deal with training etc etc
and if that was demonstrated i would be
more than happy to go against officer's
recommendation to to building the green
belt um
and again it's slightly unsustainable
location so
i want to support this and i want to
support local business and i think mr
turner's
tremendous you know
and i've got so much admiration for what
he's doing and what he's done um i would
never be able to do any of these things
so
it's brilliant so but i'm just not quite
happy from the planning point of view so
unfortunately my head is overall in my
heart at the moment and i will be
supporting officer adminitation
so it's not quite right but i think it
can get there so that's that's my fear
i'm afraid
okay in my list i've got council
jennings then councillor curtis
and i'd like to concur with what you've
just said i mean i think this the
business and i'd love to be able to say
yep
um
you deserve a house
because of all the great work you do but
unfortunately and i know that when this
came before us last time
there were elements there which we kept
on saying well
yes like a director they can live down
the road there's already there's someone
on site you can hire a you can hire a
security firm you know there are there
are options
um
with the caravan site it keeps on saying
yep it's at least 50 percent occupied
all the time that's sort of it's almost
like you don't want to read that if you
want to support this which i'd love to
be able to support it but you know if it
was saying we have one caravan on there
it's a complete disaster the business
has gone down the toilet it's
it's it's not it's not happening so we
need to use it for something else
um you then at least got rid of one of
these reasons to go against it
um
since last time there hasn't really been
much difference
from where we're from where we were sort
of the things haven't been ticked off if
they were to come back and tick these
things off you know yeah i'm happy happy
to go for it but there's been no change
from last time and i know i say that
regressively
because i think what they're doing is is
is admirable really impressive but
unfortunately this
this doesn't seem to be right
completely agree uh counselor curtis
sorry
i'm just um
council jameson mentioned that the um
the the thought we might be sitting at
precedent but i think
you know if we were to allow you know
have fields full of of love vehicles and
so forth but i think we're we're
frequently reminded that decisions that
we make as a committee don't actually
set a precedent um and
just just an additional point if i may
just picking up the the point of it
employment use i'm sorry i can't find
the page in here but we're not looking
at in this instance
um
at a loss of employment
so
is there a distinction that we can make
between
the loss of employment which there
clearly isn't
in this case
against the loss of a site that
currently offers
employment
by removing the caravan site there is no
loss of employment
because the same person is still being
employed by the company so it seems
surely a lot of employment should be
measured
by a job lost in this case there clearly
isn't
okay
right
did you want to come back on a point
that council dixon was making thank you
um
actually if i may can i start with the
issue of loss of employment as i said
before
members shouldn't be treating that as
determinative
let's
let's say for the sake of argument that
members do conclude that the loss of
employment is not a reason to refuse
this application
that wouldn't change our recommendation
in the slightest
if we took all of that element out it
does not change the officer
recommendation based on your policies
based on decisions that you have taken
in the past it doesn't change our
recommendation
so that's the first point
um second point was the issue of the the
cottagers and the tight of the business
and you're absolutely right councillor
dixon the the cottagers are tied to the
business
lodges soldiers lodges cottages
lodges my apologies i i wrote
um
so we have two lodges that are tied to
the business we have a listed building
that's a dwelling that's used in
conjunction with the business in fact we
have six dwellings on site
and what we haven't heard anything on as
part of this application is why one of
those six dwellings cannot provide the
management and supervision that they're
looking for if you look at the plan in
front of you you'll see that there's a
red line which is the application site
and there's a blue line which is other
land in the same ownership
and immediately next to the application
site you'll see there's a bungalow
called streamways
amy showed you a photograph of it in her
presentation or at least of its garage
that's in the same ownership
we haven't heard anything from the
applicant
about why that bungalow can't provide
the supervision that they're looking for
if this was an application for
any other
workers dwelling in the open countryside
that's exactly the information we would
be looking for what accommodation do you
have on this business how
do you use that accommodation how is it
that this accommodation cannot provide
you with the essential
management that you have to have on site
and we haven't heard anything of that
from the applicant now if they want to
submit that's part of a separate
application dale i'm gonna cut you off
there cause i think you're in danger of
becoming and debating on this one so
you're here to provide this information
so i'm gonna cut you off unceremoniously
there right uh councilman
mr chairman
um
help me i i
again i started off by supporting this
i'm
i'm probably going back listening to
counselor crump and put in um
can i change your mind on this
um
and listen to the uh dale as well so um
i'm betwixt in between at the moment mr
chairman uh
listen to a further debate on this so uh
i'll reserve judgment at the moment
thank you okay councillor fleming
to take
mr barker's point um they've got x
number of properties with people that
you know all these properties may well
be fully occupied and not one of the
people within those properties has the
skill to do what the occupant of the new
bungalow is going to be
so
that kind of for me on a personal level
that means that you haven't got anybody
to do that and i still see the the uh
the employment there's a net gain of one
because
nobody's losing their job because the
caravans won't be there and you'll be
moving somebody else onto the site to
live in the bungalow so rather than say
there is no there's no uh employment
loss there actually is an employment
gain because you'll have one extra
person on the site though shaking his
head so obviously that doesn't stand
right okay i'm gonna push this up we've
got a proposition which made by me uh
that we refuse this application for the
reasons that have been stated and we're
in the report i'm going to ask to see if
we've got a second for that otherwise we
need to go to something else don't we so
do i have a second of that council at
jennings seconds that
um
no other proposition has been made by
anyone yet so unless anybody wants to
put their hand up now make a proposition
i'm going to go to the vote on this
first on this first proposition
councillor dixon
one of the questions i posed was if we'd
identified that there we don't believe
there's harm to the green belt
did we need special circumstances to
as it were support the application that
i didn't get an answer to dale if i can
ask for a very brief one sentence answer
on that one
or less
i can't get into less than a sentence
if if you're satisfied there's no harm
to the green belt then you don't need
visual very special circumstances
right
council mills sorry miss jim just come
back
oh on the nearest residence that
bungalow there that's that's not empty
that's people living in that bungalow
are they
my entire point chairman is we don't
know
yes and it's not part of the application
it's part of the owners it's owned by
the applicant but it's not part of the
application site right
okay right we've it's been proposed and
seconded that we refuse this application
so i think we go to a vote on that and
see where we are all those in favor of
refusal please show
two three three okay three those against
four four
abstentions
one
right
okay over to you guys
come up with something for me
i would propose that we actually grant
it on the basis that there is no
perceived harm to the green belt
okay that's proposed is it yes
councillor curtis
for the same reasons
let me give dale a second
do you have any sets of conditions
you've got conditions
i agree with you tomorrow it's okay so
it's standard
materials
thank you oh we have got some so i'm
sorry
we have a set of conditions
i think what we want to hear from from
members chair is about this tie to the
business yes
and if they want to do that
uh other than that
it's very standard out of interest would
that tie be legally enforceable
your solicitor i'm sure can answer that
well yeah i mean if it's put in a legal
agreement it will be legally enforceable
um it's whether you consider that the
legal agreement is necessary the tie is
necessary to make this development
acceptable
um if you if you're happy with that then
i think we could put something in a
legal agreement that's legally
enforceable can we go counselor dixon is
that something you'd want to pursue i
don't think we need to i think this
property is intended for a single
occupier and i think that is as we heard
previously for the continuation of the
family business essentially and i don't
think we would need to put that into a
legal agreement okay council courtesy
are you content with that as well
would there be removal of permitted
development rights on
are you this with that as well
okay
members what do you want
you would account scouters would you
remove uh permitted development rights
or would you leave them as they are
permitted development rights would be
fairly restricted on a single-story
bungalow it would probably only be able
to go back eight meters would it no we
can't even do that because that applies
to build ones built before 2018 anyway
so you're happy um
would it make a difference
would they be able to have limited
knowledge how far would they go back in
your expertise
i can't remember
they can do quite a lot on this big site
they can do quite a lot
okay yes removal of permitted
development rights in respect of
outbuildings and
those parameters well i would feel more
comfortable yeah given what's been
proposed yeah counts right okay
are you all happy we've got everything
we need
okay right uh it's been proposed and
seconded that we grant this application
go to vote all those in favor please
show
okay those against
two abstentions please
okay okay
therefore the committee resolves to
grant application reference twenty one
slash zero three four eight two slash
ful
okay
we go to our last application of the
evening
i'll give a second movement time bit of
movement time
okay so
committee we moved to our final
application this item six of tonight's
agenda on page 41.
uh this is application reference then
21-03229 slash f2l this is 19
barton meadow welford
is for the singles single story side
andrea extension presenting officer joe
brooke joe over to you thank you chair
the application is located with wealth
non-haven as indicated by the black box
for you
the site is located within the village
conservation area and public footprint
runs along the southern and east
boundary of the application site so just
for reference this is the application
site
the public footpath as you can see
by the green dash lines
run along the application site and also
out that way as well i should say
the application seeks planning
permission for a single story side and
rear extension
so these are the existing elevations so
this is number 19 which is part of the
application
and this is the semi-attached train on
the other side i would advise to take
note of the garage
existing south elevation and these
elevations and the floor plant
and this is the proposal the extension
would be single story in height and
whilst the pro side extension would
serve a garage and have a dual pitch
roof and gable to side which would
essentially mirror the style of the
other attached arrows within the street
scene the maximum height of the
extension will be six meters 2.7 to
eaves and a width and depth of 6.6
meters
and these are the photos of the actual
site so
this is the property here apart the
application this is name and dwelling
with the taps garage
this is the public footpath so the
property will be cited to the left just
there
this is a dwelling house that's where
the guys would be sighted and this is to
the rear of the property so the uh
rear extension will be
within beyond the fence line and the
garage would be sitting there
in consideration the area is developed
on national policy and guidance as well
as the relevant statutory consultations
the officer recommendation is grant
subject to the recommended conditions as
sat out in the office report there are
no updates thank you
thank you joe go to our first speaker
council neil appleton for welfare parish
council
thank you
i'm afraid i'm afraid we've had a
discussion beforehand they didn't meet
our requirements for the type of slides
there
but sorry
that's okay i'm sorry we can't show
those but maybe reference for next time
okay
okay
so you have three minutes if you stay
seated for any questions at the end i'll
give you a warning bell at 10 seconds if
that's all right thank you very much
yes good evening councillors um
with respect to
this application
um the parish council considered it
on 2nd of november of last year
and there was much about it that parish
was prepared to support but the
proximity of the garage extension to the
historic public right-of-way
to the south was a blocking concern
the parishioner's objection is supported
by two lines of evidence
first other recent developments adjacent
to these paths known historically as the
alley and the elimi are features that
reduce impact upon them
so one is three bundles croft
it is close to where the alley emerges
onto headland road
permission for an extension over the
garage was granted in 2002 it includes a
low ridge and a hit roof to reduce
impact upon the path
a pre-existing norway maple further
softens the design particularly when it
isn't leaf another example is red maple
is a bungalow at the other end of the
path
where the limey emerges onto headland
road permission for a single story
extension was granted in 2020 despite
its close proximity it is barely visible
over the fence thanks to the roof design
which has a shallow pitch and a low
ridge
now barton meadows was built after
appeal in 2013. it too has a number of
features that reduce impact upon
footpath
um banner homes did the following
they moved the development boundary
gifting land to widen the footpath
corridors
the footpath corridor along the eastern
edge which is near plot nine and along
there so it's not in these photographs
um
is about six meters wide
the footpath corridor adjacent to number
three number 19 barton meadow which you
can see there
is only about three meters wide so the
footpath corridor is much much narrower
here
um they also built i don't know it's on
there yes you can see it on the um
image to the top right
they um they built about a garage which
has a hip roof
so that it doesn't have as much impact
and they oriented the garage around the
back of plot nine so the roof doesn't um
it's the cable end isn't overlooking the
footpath but actually you've got the
slope away from the footpath
and lastly and most notably they are
missing the garage at number 19.
all the before all except the affordable
homes on barton meadows have garages it
is notable that number 19 does not
so the present application includes no
feature to minimize the impact of the
design upon the adjacent footpath indeed
there is no evidence to suggest it has
been considered in the design process
which leads on to the second piece of
evidence supporting the parish council's
view and is focused upon the garage's
design
so um
yes you can see the elevations um 10
seconds sorry i'm sort of struggling
there a bit
um
i think i'll skip through this bit up if
you can ask me some questions about the
elevations that would be great
um so anyway for the parish council to
support this application represent a
change position
this can only be justified by a change
in policy or a change in design there
has been no material changing either so
the parish council view must therefore
remain unchanged
and i just have to pause you then i'm
sorry i'm afraid your time has elapsed
three minutes hopefully we can uh bring
out something to the in the questions
any questions uh from the members of the
committee
council adam thank you
could you tell me something about the
elevations that you object to please
right
so um yes the elevations are there you
can see that the um elevation at number
19
has um
a garage next to it now
in the original application from 2013
with banner homes there was an almost
identical
elevation
and this was rejected during the
planning consultation process
in favor of
a design that you see before you which
actually is one without a garage at the
side and of course the reason that it
was removed was its impact upon footpath
next to it
um it should be said that the
the garage is proposed is further
forward
than the other garages
on site so it doesn't quite fit into the
street scene quite as nicely as you
might think because it will be more
overbearing it is still subservient to
the main property which we fully accept
um but we feel um it could be
more subservient let's put it that way
that's okay thank you
yeah okay any other questions counselor
jennings
yeah the the footpath you say it's about
three meters at the moment the footpath
corridor is yeah and you the actual
footpath seems to be away from the house
and there's a green verge yeah that was
the bit that was gifted to the footpath
um originally the boundary line was very
very close to
the footpath itself it was basically a
post it was a personal wire thanks
originally so it's been given it's been
um gifted a certain amount how how big
is that that in that location it is
about i would say 70 to 80 centimeters
around the corner it's much much more
it's about a meter and a half to two
meters
any other questions
no
in that case thank you very much for
your time this evening thank you thank
you for your time councillors okay um we
have another speaker so we go to points
for clarification anybody got some
questions council mills thanks sir mr
chairman yes the um
what are the separation distances
between the fence and the proposed
application
uh yeah two seconds jail i want to get a
the actual plan that shows it best
i believe it's in my reserve slides
there you go so
if you have a look this is where the
garage is being proposed
so that it's obviously the defense line
it changes so from here to the front of
it it is
uh
1.7 meters
from that point there which is the
closest to the fence line that is 0.7
meters
okay
thanks joe thank you good counselor
jennings
no no is that your question as well
anymore
any other questions
counselor curtis yeah thanks chip um
josh just wondering um
the pressure council member mentioned
that previously
when the when the development was built
there was previously an application to
include a garage
on the side of that house
but it was
refused
relevance to this
if this committee previously refused an
application does that have any we need
to look at this application before us
only this application
sorry
okay
that point but okay right points
clarification out the way debate who
wants to kick off council jennings
so
on my calculations at the
the furthest bit is two and a half
meters away from the actual path
um and even on the the smallest bit is
the naught point seven plus point eight
so that's a meter and a half
in
henley all our paths i mean
i've got public
um footpaths and you've got buildings
right up to them and you squeeze through
i struggle to find to see
what the adverse impact is um
we have to get like i've said it before
we have to give really good valid
planning reasons to go against the
officers recommendations on this
i can't see it so i'm happy to propose
that we go with officer recommendations
and approve this thank you councillor
mills thanks for the chairman sir i as
you know i was going to look at the site
so i did look at this site
um
and
uh we've got a garage i think it does
even it up
for the street scene a lot but um
like council jennings i'm i'll be very
very difficult to find a really good
planning reason to refuse this thank you
are you seconding the second thank you
councillor anybody else want to speak on
this application
okay in that case let's go to the vote
it's been proposed and second this
application be granted all those in
favor please show
unanimous thank you therefore the
committee resolves to grant application
reference 21
0 3 2 2 9
fu l i don't think we have any urgent
business this evening so in that case
i'll declare the meeting closed thank
you very much everybody good night
you